conservative media they're they're going
at it with each other yeah that's what
it seems like interesting this is a very
liberal thing to do yeah
amongst conservatives no but usually
Liberals are the ones that like consume
their own right it's like you can't be
liberal enough and eventually everyone
cancels each other and it's over but
seeing the right fight like this the
independent right this is peculiar so
what it seems like uh Stephen Crowder it
was negotiating with the daily wire
which Ben Shapiro has an ownership stake
in I assume and they're close and he was
negotiating and then some phone calls
during the negotiations were before they
fell apart Stephen Crowder taped that
and then put it on this YouTube video
and explained this is why I'm not going
with the daily wire daily wire might
have said something first this is the
link fa sent us and maybe this was his
response and he was like look this is
why I'm not going to the Daily wire
apparently Ben Shapiro's deals with
these people or daily Wells daily wires
deals with Talent is you have to make
videos that YouTube won't demonetize and
that's the only way you get paid because
if we we have to make money off the
YouTube money for you to make money off
of us and Stephen Crowder's thing is
yeah but big Tech tends to lean left and
censor true right-wing views and get
demonetized so you're suppressing
freedom of speech I can't do the deal
that was his line of thought which makes
sense but then he plays the phone call
on the video and then at the end tries
to get people to his like whatever thing
he's starting so I think the response in
the the comments was not what he
expected I think he expected I'm
fighting for the truth and people are
going to see that and be on my side but
everybody in the comments is like why
would you record a phone call with your
homie and then put it out there like
yeah who does that and if he's just
getting it
was it the owner of the daily wire named
I think Jeremy boring Jeremy yeah yeah
yeah yeah and to his credit he hasn't
turned off comments I'll give him that
he's letting them cook them I thought it
was an interesting criticism though if
well okay so I understand like kind of
where both sides are coming from right
which is you know I think maybe Crowder
was looking for a deal that was probably
more similar to like rogans which is hey
I'm gonna do what I want to do and you
guys are gonna have to deal with the
repercussions of those conversations
like Rogue gets paid whether or not
Spotify gets heat Spotify wants to take
down an episode like Rogan getting
picked yeah and I imagine any creative
would want to do that you know what I
mean I also Imagine any creative would
want to eventually have that kind of
security it's like you know crowd is
probably dealing with every single week
whether an episode demonetized or not if
he's going to get kicked out of YouTube
or not if sponsors are going to leave or
not it's just there's some stress to
that so the idea that you get to go to a
company and you get this guaranteed
check after all this hard work and
building up this audience you're like
okay that's nice I finally have some
security maybe I'll take a little less
than I can make on my own for the
security that I don't have to look over
my shoulder every second to see if I'm
getting canceled by this that or the
other and then finding out that the deal
was contingent on the content being up
you go well [__] now I can't just create
freely I'm still dealing with all the
stress I had to deal with before it
ain't a real 50 million dollar deal it's
a 50 million dollar as long as I play by
the rules and it's a 50 million dollar
budget from what he's saying which is I
got to pay 25 employees for the length
of this deal right and then yeah and but
what's what's what's what he's also I
imagine frustrated by which I also
understand is if I got to play by these
rules and as a conservative I feel like
these rules aren't protecting my values
and beliefs that's not a secure system
for for me yeah I want to be able to
create whatever so in order for me to do
that I have to do that I guess on my own
platform I get that now I also
understand the daily wires position
which is like we are assuming the the
the responsibility we're assuming that
the liability we're putting up all the
money we need to make sure that your
content still makes us money yeah and
that's how a business works right if you
can't make us money then we're just
losing money on this deal we cannot do
that that not to mention I also
understand their frustration which was
the first one none of these deal points
were set in stone this is just like an
offer letter there's another term for it
I'm messing it up so he could have
negotiated on any of these points and
they're like we could have talked about
it that's where Candace came in and
Candace was like hey I got sent a deal
memo and then my lawyers change and
change these things and added different
things and created more Securities for
me you could have still done this it
looks like you're kind of making it
looks like you're kind of almost like
using this as an opera opportunity to
create a villain and then Galvanize your
audience against that villain just one
pushback he did he did do that though
like what's that like they when they
gave him the initial uh terms he did
renegotiate and say Hey I want the
contract to look like this and then they
told him like we can't match that well
my understanding is like okay so I'm
gonna walk away well my understanding
was what he changed was mostly the money
so they initially they offered something
and then handed on YouTube and the
YouTube like thing that he has to abide
by the YouTube rules he wanted that off
they were like but just real quick on
this so yeah so and which is good
because he should put that in if it's
important to have that like if it's
important to him to have that kind of
creative freedom
um the one problem is when you do accept
a deal you are accepting a lack of
Freedom anytime you accept money from
somebody else there's going to be a
restriction with that money so if you
were going for a buyout right
you have to accept hey they might take
down a piece of content they might not
want to put it up and that's up to them
and they're basically putting it on you
to create content that won't get taken
down by YouTube which I understand his
frustration what I thought was that
daily what I was trying to say is hey
you were okay with this
you weren't upset at this when the num
when you want a specific number and then
when you found out that we weren't going
to pay you that number
then you were upset so I think their
position was hey you're willing to
acquiesce to these demands for 100
million or whatever the [__] you wanted
and the second it became this different
number now all of a sudden you're you
can't do it and you're worried about
online censorship and all these things
you have to go public with it anyway
like you try to do a deal with someone
the deal doesn't work out why is that
grounds to all of a sudden like put
everyone on black and I think that's his
mistake I think you remember that Tom
Brady what do you think well I'm like
the more like malicious versus like oh
I'm this thing happened and I'm gonna
leverage this thing within the
conservative Community to like get rally
people and Galvanize people and pull
some of their fans away and eat up some
of their people I don't know if he's
thinking that way and it would be a
shame if that was but that is how it
gets perceived it would be like if
coffee Zilla did the Logan video and
then was like if you want an nft you can
trust come to me right no we're like no
now what about let's use let's use us as
an example you know we had a deal for a
special and then I publicly said what
was going on right and that I bought it
back and I was going to put out myself
like is that the same thing I don't
think so because that's necessary for
the product you're explaining to people
hey here's where it's going to be and
here's why it's going to be here but for
him nothing changed he's doing the same
thing he's saying like I want to put out
a product they are making the they are
tying my hands two differences sorry let
them just get the whole thing out of
time my hands so I can't make the
product that I want to make and so
because of this I want to let the world
know that this is the reason and why I'm
not going with this deal and he was he
wanted to emphasize like oh so every
single person that you sign even this
young YouTuber you're going to
um hold their hands as well you know I
think that was his major so here's the
pushback in terms of the answer parallel
Andrew didn't say first of all he also
didn't he went he didn't he didn't name
the streamer and still hasn't didn't
technically neither did I don't think
technically neither did uh Crowder I
think he just called him big con but no
that phone call where he taped it and
then but that's where it's different
people are like yo why are you taping
phone calls and putting them out and
vilifying people he kind of vilified
like streamers I guess but he didn't go
at anybody he didn't name any names I
vilified the idea of like censoring he
didn't at the end say by the way Comics
if you want to go to a place that won't
censor you I I'm starting a thing
it has why yo this starting to see more
selfish also I will say one thing is uh
I had a deal in place whereas the
difference here is they didn't have a
deal it'd be one thing if if they had a
deal in place they were operating within
that deal and then all this censorship
started and he needed to get out of the
deal so that he could create the content
that he was promised he could do then he
would go hey this is what happened but I
guess to your point which is like you
don't even really need to share this at
all I guess that's my question I wonder
if he has a different motivation if
there's a different like play here like
well like what the Chappelle thing with
Chappelle shows that he was leveraging
his audience to then get something that
he wanted because there was a deal that
was in place and then he was able to
leverage his audience to get a better
deal and I'm like okay yeah that's
business but like with this like you
don't just go and blast for every person
that you have a deal with that like
doesn't go through but do you think that
he was leveraging it to build up his his
patreon or his private club or whatever
it is yeah I guess feels like maybe that
was the goal I think um the way I
perceived it it was just like he was up
upset that they tried to make it seem
like it's a money thing because they I
think came at him I don't know who came
back he released first so he said he
like dissed them they came back trying
to make it seem like he was all about
the money that I think is what pissed
him off because he's like no no there's
a bigger principle at play and that's
why now I have to record this guy and
air that out so you guys see what I
actually was caring about on the phone
because he mentioned that multiple times
he's like hey
you go no sorry I was going to say to
you I was gonna go ahead finish up yeah
and so um and that's why at the end of
his thing he was like oh well you guys
can go to this platform and I want to
let you know I'm never going to sign
anybody I'm not going to own any of your
show I'm not going to take any money
from your YouTube so it's like it's
almost like even if he's trying to bring
people to this other platform I don't
think he capitalizes he should
monetarily I think he's just saying
exactly producers dancing in the video
yeah you want to come over exactly what
the [__] was it uh Death Row Record
that's exactly what I was gonna say but
it's also you come here and now you can
be yourself that feels very soon as
exactly and then the third the first
part of oh they attacked me so I'm gonna
come back I completely get it I would
probably do the same thing at the very
least want to do the same thing but Tom
Brady remember you commented on little
Duval's IG post randomly about some meme
Duval head and he said if you're
explaining you're losing that's how I
felt about watching that oh this is what
they mean if you're explaining you're
losing if you just ignored it and couple
sentence his maybe and then went on
about his business everybody had
forgotten when you make this video to
explain yourself then people start to
there's just more time to pick holes in
what you're saying
I just maybe he just felt like nah
they're trying to paint me I get it in a
light that I would have probably done
the same I mean not more sense but also
don't leave the phone call that'd be the
only thing yeah yeah
I don't I don't like that at all yeah
um but it is an interesting thing like
you know one way of looking at it is
that he went into this with the because
it's not like he hasn't had deals before
right like he's he's taking money from
different people I think he was with the
blaze I think he's been with other
people so it's not like he's not
accepting money from different groups I
guess he felt that those groups weren't
like impeding on his freedom of thought
and he knows for a fact that YouTube or
different social media platforms are
going to do that and if he has to
maintain the rules of those platforms
Now by proxy of that relationship and
that contract he cannot create freely
that I uh relate to and that would be
frustrating yeah and it'd be frustrating
for him to continue to be authentic and
serve his viewers yeah of course if he
went along with that I guess I would say
is like why not continue continue
debating that and why not continue
working those things out in the
contracts and trying to fight for that
because especially if I'm taking him at
face value in terms of like what his
beliefs are right which I like to do
with people it's like if you're
conservative leave the [__] you live
you've died I think a lot of people who
are necessarily haters are using this as
an opportunity to be like see you're not
about that life get the [__] out of here
you're just trying to monetize us but if
you believe in conservative values like
like a hot like a terrorist believes in
Islam like you are a hundred percent
anything that's going to encroach on
that freedom you like get the [__] out
of here and that's what he sounds like
to me
but you never know they could and also
there's Catholic terrorists too I just
wanted to point that out yeah that's a
fact there's a lot of different
terrorists come in all shapes and sizes
and religions yeah yeah I'm sure there's
Jewish terrorists there's definitely
Jewish terrorists the media there's yeah
there was an Asian one last year yeah
Asian there's so many different
terrorists exactly does that did what we
just said comply with all YouTube's
demands like Okay YouTube is fine
everyone's in Terrorist all the time
everyone's encouraged oh wait there's
women also there's women Terrors too
there's there's definitely women and
there's Gators gay terrorists for sure
there's they was after me in Paris bro
when they saw this mustache them gay
terrorists
nothing happen bro
on
they wanted that but then you know
that's why that's why the first time I
was in Paris I [__] myself because they
need to know what they're getting into
oh
[__] he was just playing defense yeah
he's like oh they gonna smell the Paris
on me I gotta yeah yeah okay okay I get
it now damn [__] be on it yeah